welcome to what is now the 17th session
in this series worlds of speculative
fiction this time we're looking at Orson
Scott Card and this is actually an
author who I haven't read and read
because of recommendation really happy
with with the results when there's a few
others coming up who I'm only reading in
part because other people were good
enough to recommend them to me so we're
gonna we're gonna look at as usual the
narrative world of the underverse we can
call it and I've got a number of
philosophical themes and picked out that
I thought were kind of interesting
there's probably a lot more because he
turns out to be is that I was surprised
a very philosophical out there so the
themes that I've got in very short are
reasons of state and how they apply you
know ethically to individuals
understanding and conflict between
species the what he's calling the
ansible and the phillip colonic link
different sides of a single person
speaking for the dead and the value of
truth and then if we give to a
theologies of control and theologies of
wonder so before we go into the
biography bit like I said I'm really
happy with this this choice I was
genuinely surprised by how much
philosophical and theological range card
has in these fairly short novels I mean
they're not they're not super long but
now you know george RR martin thick
tollens and there aren't really that
many characters packed in either so he
gets a lot of mileage out of it I would
say that you know speaking as a
philosopher and somebody who appreciates
sort of a grasp of philosophy worked out
in a way that you don't need to know the
philosophy in order to for it to be
explained to you in the novels Orson
Scott Card is a rival to philip k dick
who was a master at doing that that sort
of thing so that's that's pretty high
praise from me other people might have
other points of comparison I looked up
some useful interviews that I think
distill some of his mindset and his
approach and there were some interesting
passages that jumped out at me the first
one was really kind of curious he's
talking about you know he's a sci fi out
there and so he's he's within a long
tradition because he's still living
author of many people who have been
writing sci-fi and he says sci-fi has
been seen as the predictor of future
technologies but we who write and read
within this great new literary community
broaden beyond those boundaries long ago
when we speak of science fiction's role
in our culture there's two answers
sci-fi movies remain the place where we
see the spectacle of strange times and
places were impossible machines and
creatures can be made to seem to live
the place of magic so so what he's
saying as sci-fi movies are really
fantasy movies and larger spider print
sci-fi has a far more potent role of
preparing us as a culture not for any
particular future but rather for the
fact that every single human being is
writing a time machine and to
unpredictable futures one day at a time
that's an interesting thing to say the
skills needed to thrive in an
ever-changing world include the ability
to grasp new realities to notice changes
and remember them and to change our own
role to fit the new rules these are
precisely the skills acquired and
practiced by those who write and those
who read science fiction it's the mental
training ground that will keep our
culture supple and adaptable and
therefore more likely to be able to
survive whatever changes come so I I
think this that's a very strong
distinction movies are sort of like
playgrounds and they're fun and we can
chat about them but there's really it's
just kind of you know entertainment and
then you know sci-fi
novels or short stories they're doing
something very different they're
preparing us for thinking out you know
alternative realities or for us
realities that are on the horizon like
if we're thinking about what AI is going
to do 20 years ago it was all just
science fiction now we're in the realm
where and you know we see almost daily
some some new article about what you
know what's getting phased in and who's
getting phased out so I think that it's
a really really bright thing to say
when did you say that roughly do we know
what you're oh I don't know that's a
good question out of the years on here
and these are from some of these are
from his back far back is like 2000 some
of them are much more recent I think
this one was from like maybe even there
the late 90s early 2000s now another
another thing that he says it's not
counterintuitive but goes contrary to a
lot of people of writing say is he says
you know Tolstoy had said you know good
people are kind of boring so he says
good people are endlessly fascinating
wicked people are all weak cowardly or
evil in the same old ways I don't find
the evil fascinating I find it
predictably self-serving good people are
the ones who struggle to balance their
own needs with the needs and loved ones
and the communities to which they've
given allegiance my villains in short
are heroes of their own stories so they
they're kind of narcissistic they they
are closed off right but they're now the
heroes my story the heroes are the ones
who keep society running who hold things
together my heroes are the people who
stay and face the consequences of their
choices their parents who try to be good
to their kids in place them before
career entertainment their spouses who
stay together even when adultery calls
finning goes on with more examples I
think this you know this means that he's
not talking about like white hat versus
black hat good
is evil because the good people are
usually going to be viewed by a lot of
people as actually not being good people
they're because they're the ones who are
actually two people work of holding
everything together and not not just
appearing to be doing the right thing
but actually doing the right thing which
usually goes unnoticed all the testing
that reflects these Latter day Saints
upper end - I think you're right about
that I think that that's reflected in
those statements yeah and I think that's
something it's not something that you
would only find it from say latter-day
saint because I think you'd find other
other authors from other spiritual
directions saying similar things about
it's really about doing the right thing
even though it's gonna cost you oh yeah
the one of the things that's kind of
interesting with the Latter day Saints
here in America is they've managed to
retain their distinctive you know
culture and ethos more more strongly
than most other religious groups have
there's there's others that have done so
like the Amish or you know various other
conditions the last sentence because
Latter day Saints it's a very strong
message on families yeah yeah and a very
strong message on you stay together as a
married couple no matter what yeah and
there are the religions that say that
yeah but not to the same extent it's a
much stronger message I think within
life facing yeah part of the thing
because there's a more traditional
emphasis on a marriage is not
fundamentally about you you know finding
pleasure in the other person or just
being compatible they you know the
things that we've turned it into in
Western culture where it's like well
let's be married until we're not married
you know that's most states it now have
no-fault divorce
it was a long time
state still don't but most do yeah the
states the to new the divorce rates are
way higher you know so I think yeah
maybe maybe that's right
speaking of religion so here's another
interesting thing that he says I'm tired
of books that get short shrift to
religious people and one that you bother
to attempt to deal with religion they
always get it wrong well that's kind of
an overstatement but for instance
anybody who's not a Mormon rates about
Mormons they get it so laughably
hopelessly wrong what this tells me is
that whenever I write about a culture I
don't belong to
I'm undoubtedly doing the same thing
making so many mistakes that to a member
of that culture I'm embarrassing myself
the only thing I can do is to study the
best I can and learn as much as I can so
I can embarrass myself as little as
possible so we're gonna see him for
instance writing about Calais right the
Catholic Church plays a major role in
the second and third books the result is
that as in writing about other religions
and other cultures the more I know the
more possibilities of the characters the
more stuff comes out of the culture it
allows me to plumb my own
unconsciousness at the same time I wish
other writers would include more of
their characters religious life of their
stories and take the time and effort to
try to get it right even if it's
impossible to succeed completely I think
that's that's an interesting thing to
say there are you know there are writers
who do a fairly good job in writing
writing about religious characters and
their motivations and things like that
but they usually tend to be people who
either are from that community or have
left that community and are still sort
of like looking back and rather than
people you know totally outside of that
community with Mormons and Catholics
there's kind of a here in the United
States sort of little bit of trivia
there's an interesting connection in
that you know Catholics when when they
were a minority
in largely you know sort of evangelical
protestant we're gonna protestant
spectrum thing
regardez kind of aunt non-american
anti-american there are a lot of lot of
things that circulated around like they
publish these books and awful
revelations you know what's happening in
the nunnery you know and how they're
getting getting it on with the priests
and burying the babies or all this sort
of stuff and all of that turned out to
be nonsense oh there are worries about
like you know the Pope is gonna the Pope
is going to take over the United States
and so we have you know the nativism
Antica Tolleson kennedy grants well it
was before that but but i mean it was
still around at service to get what well
here's what's in it really interesting
the same tropes got recycled the the the
height of the anti-catholicism in the
1800's of is like the 1830s and 40s
those same tropes got recycled when they
were dealing with the mormons they just
changed the faces they changed the names
now instead of it being a nunnery where
all this stuff is happening it's out the
desert and they would they would do the
same sort of boilerplate fiction
disagree with that someone because I
think in the 1850s seventies whatever I
mean the religious orientation and the
United States focused on two big issues
and and maybe that's because the mass
media I would say at the time yeah
newspapers and Telegraph's and so things
travel but whatever it was really
slavery the idea that we could treat
somebody as subhuman yeah when they saw
them as human and the other was polygamy
yeah with you it was not just that was
real to people oh my god that I think
they said we have to cast this out
because this is not marriage this is not
you know well you're great and that's
what they didn't they basically cast
them in New York to Illinois to say get
out here to the desert now you're out of
sight out of mind and so a lot of most
of the anti-mormon stuff is when they're
out of the desert after
select the 1870s you know the sort of
tracks that I'm talking about where they
just took the old sort of the
anti-catholic tropes and then recycled
them it wasn't popular yet I think that
the anti-catholic said she was
anti-immigrant was both characters to a
church in a foreign language I mean
there were a lot of oh sure sure yeah
there was the Mormons we're not
immigrants no they were their daily
letters or something they did themselves
as being like the true Americans it's up
over and over again
in terms of the other yeah because it's
it's back with Islam it's back with
Sharia law
that seems know what's gonna happen it's
right back and it happens in every
immigrant group could happen with the
Chinese it happened with when the
Italians came it happened when the Irish
came it happened when the Russian Jews
came you could look at any dynamic of
the other and we don't understand them
as a different language different
religion a different what else are we
gonna take older there is gonna take
over all of us I mean them to be fair
with the Latter day Saints they actually
haven't organized army and stuff like
that so there wasn't worried that hey
those guys may you know they've got Utah
they may try to take other other places
and so that we brought the army to deal
with them back then well that was after
after the Civil War but it's funny that
going on with this so he also talks
about communitarian values and so this
kind of that I think brings it home and
he says I bring instead of communitarian
values to my fiction it's not like
plants just who I am when you write
communitarian fiction this is kinda
interesting the fans who show up to your
signings are people who respond to
community values so I had books to our
people widely-separated they they people
say the fans and you're signing or so
patient and they're nice to each other
so many friendships begin in line and
people
changing emails and phone numbers and
taking pictures of each other's camera
people have never met before why because
the people who respond to my fiction
tend to be people who want to build
community that's not the elitist
literary view those are people who are
about writing fiction that will impress
people will make them rise above the
community
I read fiction that's about people who
immerse themselves in community and
don't think they're better than everyone
else and aren't trying to impress
everybody a very different set of values
and I get the results it's kind of I
mean he's writing this of course in a
very sympathetic source right that the
desert news is a latter-day saints
publication but there's something to
that and there's there's an interesting
contrast we're talking about literature
right we have a lot of literature that
you know people do read because
somebody's buying those books but not a
lot of people read it not a lot of
people discuss and then we and we've
talked about this before we have
literature that appeals to anyone just
want to say the common person but let's
call it the common educated person or
the common literate person the person
who takes an interest in literature but
doesn't want to go and pursue a degree
in English Lit you know they want to
read a good story they wanna they want
to read something that appeals to them
current says if that's what he's he's
orienting himself towards and so in some
respects I think it's you know it's even
better when somebody like that is able
to blend in all this really interesting
theological and philosophical and you
know cultural stuff and do it in a way
that people can say that's a really good
story you know because there are there
are people who weave in kind of high
theory into there they're worse they're
boring to read you know and you just
don't read them you pick up often
because people tell you you're supposed
to read them and you start reading it
when you're like I got better stuff to
do you know part doesn't seem to be like
that so
I know I can't say I fully I'm just feel
I know what to make of them I thought
those were some interesting features of
his his work his biography is unfinished
of course because he's not dead and
hopefully he'll be around quite a while
he's in a sixties so he could be writing
for a long time I only put the the books
that have to do with the the under seat
you know story or narrative world in
that he's written a lot of other ones
you can see he's born in 1951 starts
becoming interested in literature
his father takes a position at Arizona
State moves the family eventually takes
another position at Brigham Young like a
lot of kids whose whose parents work at
universities he goes to Brigham Young he
goes to that school he goes on a mission
a two-year mission to Brazil what's up
no I said that then it occurred to me
immediately when I was reading another
mind when he had that Lewis Latini and
that was Brazilian did this mission ever
yeah yeah do you know I'll say something
no that's kind of a side note so and
actually any of you who've read the
other novels beyond Ender's Game I'd
like the sound you out of us so I can
read a bit of Portuguese that's what
here's the thing as I'm reading through
this this novel about you know Lusitania
this planet where everybody's you know
Brazilian he puts a lot of Portuguese in
there and well and a lot of times you
put an expression so if you don't know
the Portuguese you you would be like
what the hell are they saying and I
think it would be kind of aggravating
now is that I could I could read it and
sometimes I can't someone doesn't have
to go to the dictionary
what the word actually was and I find
that aggravating myself because I don't
like to slow down right we could pull
some of the Spanish out of it a little
bit I say just take care it just kept
going I could die on a Spanish and on
context I got by on space-efficient
context there's probably some stuff like
this that would have been a bilingual
bomb yeah I have a tiny bit of
Portuguese but not enough to count so we
all at least have the advantage of being
able to puzzle out what was going on I
am the engine like for somebody who
doesn't have any of that it would be
kind of aggravating the pronunciations
and because I had this the beginning of
the book yeah and like something that
would look really different like Cuong
and it was like CEO I mean it was really
a lot of consonants together with it
should those substituted for two vowels
and so that's where I thought you know
what I love language and I love learning
things though I just got to a point you
know I had to get these books read and
other stuff done I only got three of our
read but and then I enjoyed them I
thought but yeah I did kind of put that
Portuguese yeah it doesn't interesting
this is a total digression from his you
know he went to Brazil so you know he
knows what he's doing he's he's writing
already but he's not writing science
fiction novels he's writing plays and
musicals and I only put like the first
two that he did there but he kept on
doing that because he was a theater
major and he produced these he actually
starts producing plays at this place
called the castle before that that folds
works for brigadiere your
Brigham Young University Press starts
dating woman who's going to become his
wife and then decides to become a
full-time writer
he also drinks the Democrat Party during
an election where almost everybody in
the area the Republican and so he had he
was kind of braving
things at that time
they gets married and then he starts he
starts you know writing and he actually
gets an award for best new writer on the
basis of short stories that he's
publishing starts having children and
ends up you know doing furthering his
educational track earns an MA and in
English they moved to South Bend so we
can go to University of Notre Dame but
then there's a recession and you know we
don't really think too we think about
the eighties in retrospect as being like
you know everything was was you know the
economy was booming and stuff like that
the early eighties weren't you know we
were still in crunch time yeah and so he
ends up having to drop out and start
working and they moved down to greens
Greensboro North Carolina and then
Ender's Game was was perfect was a
novella written years and years before
that but he patches it up into an actual
novel and that's his first like knock it
out of the park really big hit and he
wins the nebula and the the Hugo hat and
then it's follow-up speaker the Denny
was the nebula and the Hugo for that so
this is this is sort of like somebody
it's statistically sort of threading the
needle from across a football field
I suppose you know he was really being
recognized for his work and he continues
on writing writing books he he actually
says that he's not that prolific of a
writer he and one of the interviews I
don't remember exactly with whom he says
that he wishes he could write more than
one book a year but he just doesn't have
the the discipline to see it through the
way some people do like churn out
through four books he here
I mean I'd love to be able to write a
book a year that's pretty admirable he
that he did have two of his children
died one was was died soon after birth
or was their last child
another dies fairly young some Charles
right now he's actually
he has a permanent appointment as a
distinguished professor at Southern
Virginia University which is a LDS
school and he's still right pretty
actively and you know maintains a web
presence gives workshops all those sorts
of things the things that we're looking
at her you know much earlier I I didn't
read these these four books myself but
maybe down in the future on a wall so
let's let's talk about the narrative
world and here I think we have to talk
about a narrative world as like capital
W you know the universe and then actual
worlds because he he fills out these
planets and if you're on a planet you're
pretty much stuck on that planet unless
you take interstellar flight and then
you're cutting yourself off from from
time and the people on your planet
because by the time you get to somewhere
everybody's old so it really is a matter
primarily of different planets
and it gives us a lot of glimpses of
some of these worlds earth you know in
under Ender's Game
this eros the place where the command
school is based Lusitania is is the main
place for two of the books Trondheim or
all these or the Swedes or North people
that was with a walk with four letter
word names that's true kill kitty and
then you know we get paths where the
Chinese are there's some other ones that
we get introduced to as well those are
the ones where most of the action seems
to be happening and each of these gets
settled by a different culture has its
own economy its own religious outlook so
Ganges is you know influenced by
Hinduism path you know traditional
Chinese philosophy and religion of
course Lusitania Catholic you know
Brazil and what we've got here
is the spread of humanity out into the
cosmos after we win a major war with the
first species first real intelligent
species we encounter and we discover the
ansible technology from them which
allows communication at a distance which
is really convenient and it in a
narrative way because otherwise how
would anyone know what's going on
anywhere else
we saw versatile Kayla Queen did this to
you remember with it takes forever to
fly anywhere but you can even
communicate so that's an important
literary device I think with him with
card it's it allows these massive
computer towers that are coordinating
things across space and time in in the
earlier books you know we've got this
sort of power struggle happening on
earth and then then by the time of the
second book we have the starways
Congress and they're sort of running the
show from from a distance
we finally get another place later on
this outside the outside of normal space
and time where souls or not even sure
it's all walls this Hawaiian it's a
revolt
yeah but these yeah so there there's a
there's another place that's brought
into the mix and then everything unfolds
within that and and we have you know we
should really say four main races
although there's only one of the races
there's only one representative of it
which is Jane the AI she is a different
species so to speak of the humans who
are the dominant species after they
displace the formics
you know the hive Queen and and then we
the the Piggy's a Caminos right I'm
probably mispronouncing that and then we
have the hive Queen after her species is
yeah yeah but words in there piggies
that's right yeah yeah ascending but
that's alright well but we need Escala
door seals gonna see the testicle
addressed though oh yeah we see ladoris
well so I'm gonna clear what is that was
that a I don't I think what when I ended
yeah I ended with the children of the
mind you probably read more of the books
to the did it ever did they ever come
into some sort of a species they know at
the time they were just trying to
determine if they did well there are
masses over there are species so this is
actually let's listen let's transition
to talking about one of the key themes
maybe at least we made a handout perfect
for this about that anywhere else the
hierarchy of foreign keys yeah that's
that's the fundamental question all
right I think we're do these where do
they fit in and so you notice that under
his sister Valentine comes up with this
cool hierarchy of how different people
are from each other so level one is a
stranger who's recognizes belonging to
one's own species from the same planet
but a different area so we'd all be that
I supposed to to each other in so far as
we don't all live in exactly the same
place but we're really pretty close
because we all live here in the Greater
Milwaukee area right so we wouldn't even
be that level in foreign to say to each
other and sort of these animals that
would qualify that because fellow me and
dad say you know this guy comes from
France and this guy comes from sweet and
and and you know some of them are
actually kind of character Spanish guy
is obsessed with honor and all that sort
of stuff but they're they're brought
together and at that level there can be
misunderstandings and conflicts as their
art but at least you know where people
are coming from and you share some
common maybe language or something like
that and then we have the friend leg
which we don't we don't have any
experience with that yet so this is
somebody from a different planet which
means they're literally from a different
and examples would be under in Valentine
in relation to pretty much everybody
because nobody else is from from Earth
usually the Lusitania is in relation to
people from other planets like the
people from Trondheim were the people
from path or although they would be
friend links to each other and now we
start getting into the really
interesting stuff the Raman sentient
beings members of the different species
but who can be understood to be human so
here's where like we could make
comparisons
perhaps if we make advances in animal
behavior studies right let's say we
discover that that we can actually
communicate with all offense would they
would they be Raman to us you know or
would they be
or else would they be a species who we
can't there's no real basis for for
commonality and communication with I
think they probably Raman I think
there'd be Raman that's what I would
yeah and and if they honor then we we
have certain ethical obligations to them
you know like if we know that another
species has you know experience is
similar to our own then we'd probably
have done the Hydra trade and we
probably would have to stop using
elephants as beasts of burden in in
other places the term used in a lot of
science fiction is sentient yeah well
the Paris engine assumptions assumption
means to be aware of your surroundings
and to respond to it the question really
is can they reason and can they can they
have rational communication with us like
you know our dogs we know they like us
and they do communicate with us in all
sorts of ways like the dog
is up in a magazine stale I'm after your
home but loves its head again see it
wants to be petted starts barking at you
because it wants to be fed there's
clearly communication going on it's not
rational communication Monsieur Lassie
doing pretty good yeah that's true yeah
or cartoons right because there are
either that they're pets that know when
you're coming home from work well they
do yeah yeah they've done somebody's
there are some rational things that you
can see it's a matter of degree
yeah and and so that's that's where it
gets I mean so we're doing these
experiments like with chimps and stuff
like that because we figure they're
constructions we teach them sign
language and all that and they it's
easier to tell with them I think because
they're closer to us than it is with
other species that may be very
intelligent like like whales of dolphins
elephants great appearance yeah looks
that great period I'm familiar with him
Arina know he was he was that well
actually he got his obit in the New York
Times he was so famous but he had whoa
two to three thousand word [ __ ] have you
heard you Wow likes it but I mean he was
an also spawning like Watson yes
absolutely and he had temper tantrums
and when he was asked to do stuff and he
would he would get pissed at his at his
person and she said he'd do something
and then he would he would come back at
her with this length I mean it really
was heavy it was actually communication
and then he would community reborn
sci-fi there is come in and he would
translate to her to his handler that is
really interesting yes and and he really
education there I mean I am Chinese but
since then now I keep up with a lot of
stuff and there is so much new
information out there animals like dogs
and cats have about the the
consciousness of a three or four year
old child you know they quit
look it is quite a bit ago and I think
when you get into things like you know
higher higher sense just like elephants
and dolphins and things like that but
much higher than egg these are these
three pay
Earth's are so doggone intelligent just
funny
hey porcine yeah poor pigs that work
yeah pigs are very smart too well and
then we also the Occupy we no idea
what's going on in their heads but
clearly there's because we don't have
the same language that's what I liked
about these books is just developing you
know trying to figure out this language
like you know disk lard just go here so
so this is this level three is really
key you know and there's a lot of
discussion there about well are these
should we qualify these people as Robin
or should they be qualify them as as for
also and sort of like the buggers for
example really they were ramen but we
didn't know that and they they started
you know a war with us without realizing
they're starting war and then we went on
to destroy them that's the fourth level
that you have sentient beings that are
truly alien right they they're they're
two different from from humans there's
no really meaningful communication so
the desk Alanna discolored or eggs would
be like that right we don't at least in
those four books the humans and the
other the other races can't effectively
communicate with them they don't know
what's what's really going on
it's clear there's something going on
but they're there and and when it comes
to ramen well you're not supposed to
engage in Xenocide whereas with your
else you might have to and then there's
that fifth level the the beast that
would eat you up the juror and then they
have their they probably do have to be
wiped out and so there's a lot of
discussion about where people fit in and
it's not just the humans that have this
discussion the like in the third book
the the bikini notes are
having that and saying well we got to
wipe out all these humans so there's a
lot of interesting discussion about that
we you know when we think about what
makes us human
well we also the ei2 which is gene
mm-hmm
real concern for us given that we're
developing a eyes left and right now at
what point do we start considering their
people as opposed to slaves what they
are right now you know essentially right
mm-hmm
one of the big conversations is so
should we tax corporations that are
phasing out human labor in favor of AI
and robotics lab or should we tax them
on those robots what they're using
because we wouldn't be taxing human
workers right now if we're taxing them
it's like taxing yeah cuz nothing gas
tax
I suppose in yeah in a way that is kind
of similar things connecting with one
API with the used to board slaves as
property that's right and they were
taxed as property well AI is technically
our property of whoever produces them or
purchases them but I don't know you know
okay one one way that we'll be able to
tell that that's not going to be tenable
is when the AI is you know start killing
us for for doing that I'm trying to
think of this it's a current it's not on
now because it's just finished a little
while ago yeah it's it's about AI and it
takes place in England and these people
will have these what the heck is they
have you know they have servants maids
whatever you know their yeah but then
this this girl runs his runs this
program and she wakes him up and other
conscious some of them not all of them
but some of them are conscious and so
it's and then all of a sudden it's like
Yanks and there's a really interesting
case and one of them she
her job was to be a prostitute yeah and
she did wake up and then she understood
that she was just really getting hurt
and beaten and everything by these guys
and she retaliated Chris Davis ultimate
strength sushi
normal because it's a TV show
okay I can't think of it but anyway
she ended up killing it was a different
program so somebody's messing with the
code to wake him up yeah all right so
anyway she ended up inadvertently
killing this man went on the run and
then in the end she wanted to go to
trial to prove that she was human
oh and and they weren't the government
was trying to say well not but she was
trying to say no and and stating her
case for her humanity so I thought that
was very interesting and then it in the
second season
what the hell isn't even there's almost
like slaves there are other things that
what the hell's me with this and I think
their own yeah their own and and they
come in and they do your your will labor
and stuff for you but in the end the the
daughter of the wrong these families
ends up breaking the you know doing this
code and waken the whole dare and group
up they also were doing children so if
you wanted they have a child and you
know all of this kind of stuff yeah that
far it's one it's one way nothing
repeats right history I have it in Star
Trek next generation with data the
Android when they have a whole show
devoted to proving these seditious
humans human okay and then it shows her
again thank you with that though there's
a fundamental difference in how it's
being treated got one data right it is a
unique thing and Jane is like that too
with this sort of thing you've got an
entire like class
well the argument not yet people the
argument they'll be eight your data was
if you count him as property and then
you reproduce him over and over again
what you've done is created a class of
slaves oh yeah you create a whole class
of people yeah who are in
slaves yeah that was a part of that
argument for that but you see it pop up
again in the movie you see it pop up
again well these are the enemies are
really and over and over again these are
these are very present issues now for us
in ways that they weren't twenty years
ago and probably another 20 years we're
going to have started making some
decisions about that you know we look at
how quickly technology is progressing
well you're gonna I mean another
instances work you have their mixing
genes you know there are some human
genes in pigs you know so yeah I mean so
now are you killing I mean so at what
point do you say ah it's only 10% here
yeah there's an interesting issue in
these books so people in path right are
these Chinese descendant people and a
lot of traditional Chinese culture is
imported there but they there's this uh
gods that God speak to people well
what's really going on is it's OCD and
it's being transmitted genetically and
it turns out that it was being used by
corporations yeah to essentially get
very intelligent people to feel to be
sort of self-directed and get things
done and punish themselves if they
didn't do what they're supposed to do it
was done through genetic manipulation
you know and we could imagine a lot of
things like that going on for every like
parent who you know uses genetic
technology so that their kid is gonna be
more that genetic defect doesn't have to
suffer from that there's maybe some some
corporations like we need people more
docile you know did good workers or
whatever it'll exist yeah until exists
and I mean we have so many ethical
things coming you know turn of us and I
I kind of liked when the beginning of
guess I only read the first the Ender's
books yeah but like like an in the first
one he said he would start before his
paragraph you'd always start with
communication like in in this game it
was almost a little bit of conscience
was there because there was so much
unethical activity so much everything
was such a moral dilemma what they were
doing with these kids and everything
else but they had that little bit of
conscience in the beginning talking
about it and then they go on you know
with this battle school and then having
an eighth year or some year old child
destroy the an entire you know yeah
without even knowing it but what they
put him through there's all of these
ethical things that leads because that's
one of the key themes so what makes it
what makes it seem okay and it's
interesting the Marines actually have
people at certain levels read this book
Ender's Game because of the ethical
dilemmas and questions of leadership and
also considers its military so they kind
of get off on that too I think but
but this yeah when do you sacrifice the
individual for the greater whole so in
in ethics we talk about this typically
in terms of what we call me Tillett
Arianism which which is yeah you know it
doesn't have to be framed in terms of
pleasure and pain it can be framed in
terms of outcomes we want to maximize
positive outcomes for the largest number
and minimize negative outcomes for the
smallest number so if we have to
sacrifice some people then you know
that's that's not great but it's okay
because we're saving the larger thing so
in Ender's case right who are they
saving the whole human race it's hard to
find any value that's going to compete
with that
and yes they have to like to form all
these these kids in tournament to
cold-blooded killers who are ready to go
out to battle why are they doing that
because if they don't the buggers are
going to kill all of them well there's
also the argument that the children are
more know if they're faster the reflexes
are faster yeah because they have to be
able to control the equipment and once
you pass a certain point your reflexes
start slowing down
that's true too yeah and you see that in
the military they want young guys and
women because well if they're in a
battle they don't know
deal you want people who can move fast
and quick and who could reseal so
there's a parallel I think there is also
younger people are easier to sure yeah
yeah and that they are they're not gonna
have the same world dilemmas that older
people have because they don't have the
unique anybody experience so they can be
simple this is a game this is a game
where they're not to be pudding they
filled the the kids by telling you it
was just a game yeah but bugging me all
the while they were trained even and do
if they told them that was real and you
know the the kids are doing their thing
but there is a whole cadre of adults out
there piloting those ships that are
taking the directions from the kids that
know that it's not a game and it's it's
quite desperate and then you know there
there's that question too of well is it
okay to engage in Xenocide if your
species has got its back to the wall is
is survival of your species the
paramount moral value we made we may
face this someday hopefully not in our
lifetime sometimes people's face that
here in our society you know like what
do you think about what was going on say
during the Holocaust right or with the
Native Americans yeah work or or more
recently some some other you know civil
wars where they've really got it in for
this group and they're gonna kill them
all off well that wasn't totally
seamless I see Messiahship gone so and
it's an attempted yeah but I I think
that you know that question is can be
answered what's the dilemma said I mean
the life that enter had because he you
know until you really see how the hive
Queenie they could communicate with her
but prior to that I mean it really
they've been speaking of in dirt talk
about guy who can't let a character go
what do you haven't live like 4,000
years I don't even know if he's still
gone I didn't read anyone well if he's
still alive in the end after like why
don't we some like in Peter the last
time I
and so I don't know if you would so
we're beyond that he's in a different
body at the end because this guy can't
let a character goal I think that's an
interesting you know that's an
interesting theme actually should should
a novelist sooner or later
move on to other cameras that's a good
question after thousands of years he's
still got the same guy going from place
if he changes he's growing well provides
a perspective you don't get in somebody
who is short-lived
so there's also there's a literary
justification for it in that he can
provide some contact story I think you
just really love that in there I'm sorry
well you know maybe maybe novelists do
like not fall in love in an erotic way
but different characters actually a good
good question what is that it's doing
fanfic writers when you know there's a
female character or a writer puts
herself in certain amounts to get her
good things and make her beloved by
everyone so the original Mary Sue parody
miss Paula she fell in love with Kirk
and Spock and kind of had a whole
enterprise bowing at her feet but it was
a parody of a trend when a guy does look
he's a Marty Stewart Gary Stu just for
the ride the interest and so some people
do think you can get too in love with a
character well so this is a different
question if you're a novelist that a
perfect writing for yourself right but
you're mostly writing for your public do
you in some of your public probably with
more of this character give me more and
more but some of them probably have that
reaction or the like can't you move on
to something else do you have any sort
of duty to your readership or if you're
in the novelist can you to say hey look
it's my novels I get to do whatever the
hell I want you know it didn't slow down
the sails after the first book yes yes
you definitely wanted you just didn't
wanna be you know go yeah I mean speaker
for the dead you know you're gonna stir
see but then she does but he goes
through so many trans
not just physical but emotional and
spiritual transformations to that it
becomes very interesting and so it isn't
like it's it was a terrible thing that
you're moving them around it's just that
it's unusual that you keep a character
that long well if you're him you can see
the impact of what happens over the
stretch longest stretch your right with
Frank Herbert you get something similar
with was reaching about this yeah but
even he because he switched up two
different protagonists at some points we
know the second yeah you know so another
theme that I had wanted to talk about
was how one person can be two people and
there's an interesting like
philosophical connection with us that
I'll talk about in just a minute
so ender you know in the second book he
is under the Xenocide and everyone hates
him cuz he's the worst guy ever right
because he killed off the whole species
and he's also the speaker for the dead
and there's a point where some of the
characters have to come to terms of the
fact he is the same guy right and so
you've got these feelings towards this
and they're totally different than the
feelings towards this but they're the
same person no and then you throw in the
fact that he created the Xenocide yeah
story
oh yeah so that is another wrinkle but
he were alive right yeah he created the
zenith Xenocide era
oh yeah the high quittin in The Hitcher
the high key in the head so in
philosophy around the turn of the 19th
to 20th century there was this guy
Frigga who wrote about sense and
reference and he was a logician
essentially and he he was looking at
interesting puzzles where two things
really end up being say the same thing
but they're called by different names
and so the morning star the evening star
turned out to be both the Venus right
but people called them by different
names so they have a different sense but
they have the same reference they are
referring to the same thing so if I call
this you know daddy's little helper and
my kid calls it the iPhone we're both
we're calling it two things that very
different emotional resonances but
they're the same an actual thing it's
more complicated with human beings of
course we work much more complex beings
histories and all that but when you find
out that one that two totally different
people turn out to be the same person
there's an interesting jarring thing
that's happening there how do you how do
you assimilate these to each other we
run into what we call cognitive
dissonance how can you be under the
Xenocide this horrible person ambu this
really sensitive says the right thing at
the right time wise speaker for the dead
you know how can you possibly be both at
the same time and I think this isn't
interesting you see it early in science
fiction literature with Clark Kent
Superman well they're both good guys
though cancer camera we've seen is seen
as not much of anything
listen be sort of like if Superman has
this super-ego gene they would be
Superman and then whoever the worst
villain in Superman's Universal if
Luthor yeah if they were the same guy
now that would be okay you had you had
in you know enderwiggin and Andrew Regan
and in they word you know and Andrew was
the speaker for the dead ender was but
you know no injured was the speaker for
the death nobody but he spoke as and it
is his actual name is that and that's
why they didn't know that it was injured
and so later on it was a little funny
that nobody was like hmm Wigan that's
not
name any relationship he was three
thousand years later to what hangs lips
you conduct three thousand frigging
years yeah you're zapping yourself
around space that long you know um but
well what I thought was interesting too
is because you know now they get on
Lusitania and they've got you know
you've got this self American Bishop but
you know you didn't get much more
conventional ready today so I'm not
talking about but anyway um and and they
don't want this guy coming in because I
oh you know here's this heretic and blah
blah you know that this whole thing but
yet he has this ability you know just
this ability to come in and just you
know take over which I thought was
really kind of interesting too well he's
a commander in Guam yeah just call me
everything but I mean it just just his
eye you are or whatever is still present
so it's just yeah you know and I think
that that's what make people not think
he was really the Xenocide guy because
he wasn't really that bad you know
they could see he was just a child he
didn't know what he was doing he was
told this was a game he isn't this evil
person
you know the whole speaking for the dead
thing is kind of interesting there's
this premium placed on like bringing
truth where things are being covered up
and and all of that how do you make a
religion out of that is I don't think
that's actually the answer in the box
we just they're their own religion and
they get invited and it's you know it
makes sense why people walk you know not
necessarily like it because they don't
usually like it but but feel the need
for it right you summon a speaker for
the dead before somebody who's died so
that all the stuff can get worked
through I didn't see this religion even
is it will get your call back
we see it as a religion as much as a
what I was saying tool but that's not
really ready general because he can only
eventual more of us yeah more of a
ritual that helps people work through
Trinity you know I didn't wanted to see
I don't think because he was a you know
he would be when he was in his it was
you Neutron tightness didn't by the
Catholic bishop because it was a threat
to their auditions to get to the old
traditions and he saw that as well I
wasn't Catholic so okay it had to be
something it was though there was a line
in there that the bishop said to me
don't you have a don't you believe in
all the stuff he says well I believe in
something that's believable so right off
the bat I'm not gonna believe in all
this nonsense that you believe in
because it's just a lot of myth and
superstition says I'm going what I
believe in is believable yeah so he he
he kind of and he was always you know
having arguments for the students about
you know Calvinism and other types of
rest to you so I think he wasn't really
religious
he even entertained religious ideas so
yeah I thought it was interesting the
contrast in the second book between the
monks and their order and the pastoral
authority of about the bishop you know
you're right the bishop was kind of a
caricature you know must protect the
church the monks were like no you know
we're interested in knowledge and
passing that on but that's pretty
typical within the kathleen you've made
orders versus the diocese versus the
diocese and you have the bureaucratic
structure which is the bishops and the
Archbishop's and Cardinals and the
Vatican and the Curia you have the
Jesuits and the orders business often
got themselves and the monks and the
people who further song formation
formation and study and idea
what was still interesting though you
know what they call you children of the
light of mind of Christ of the mind of
God and they anything goes ice melt
whatever but they had they could be
married but they still don't have
celibate like it's still ahead in that's
a good transition to one of the things I
was hoping to talk about two different
so part of a religious guy and he's
writing about religious people and he's
got characters that have what you might
call a theology of control the bishop
that we're talking about he's kind of
closed off order really matters he
speaks in the place of God and he might
not necessarily believe in his own stuff
all the time but he's definitely not
going to allow any chinks in the armor
and he doesn't because somebody has to
write he's the bishop but then we can
talk about at the out what we might call
a theology and wonder and this is
represented by the the monks and by a
few other characters and this way of
looking at things is God gave us minds
so we can exercise them and that's
wonderful because there's so much cool
stuff out there and it might not fit
exactly into how we've got things
figured out in terms of you know our
religious viewpoint right now but
there's still kind of a faith that God
is still behind the whole thing
so we're going to go further and further
into it so that we understand more and
this was this little bit of driving
monks in in the Middle Ages and they
some of them not monks like Peter Damian
who said that grammar was a device of
the devil and so forget philosophy don't
forget that sort of stuff but there were
other monks well like somebody who I do
research on st. Anselm of Canterbury who
says we were given minds so that we can
understand we'd actually be falling down
on the job if we didn't use our minds to
understand as much as we can what the
the faith is opening up for for us and
and so if we adopt that sort of
perspective we start finding out how
complicated human beings are
and that there aren't simple solutions
to things and yet we stuff to try to
work out solutions and that's a very
different perspective so then when I
started thinking about it first I was
looking at this contrast in the second
book between the abbot and the bishop
but then there's that that other guy the
the priest father estado who goes out to
the piggies and dies right and he
represents sell it well he represents
the theology of hope he's not out there
to impose an order he's not out there to
threaten them he's out there to try to
work things out and he goes out there
knowing that they may kill them which I
do but but hoping and and a lot gets
accomplished
I mean oh really a lot gets accomplished
by all three of these mindsets right
sometimes it is good to have people who
are really focused on order because they
do make the trains ride that sort of
business right but you also do need to
have the people who are motivated by
curiosity and Wonder and and have a
faith that this is not going to lead
away from from whatever the divine or
that something like that but but rather
towards it and then people who embody
hope who don't know that things are
gonna turn out well and sometimes it
doesn't turn off well you know he it's
interesting because card is very
theologically tuned father estado
doesn't say things are gonna my mission
is going to be successful everything's
gonna turn out well he says God things
are gonna get sorted out the way that
God wants them I hope that it turns out
to be the way that I want them to but if
not then I'll go with what God wants and
the bishop you know makes trouble right
the bishop says you should do things
this way and the father is stopped at
one point says you know I'm supposed to
do God's will and obey the bishop if I
can only do one of them it's gonna be
God's will
so we're not too eager the bishop I
think he said right and so there's
different different attitudes towards
religion well even though Mike he knows
the piece yeah when they begin religion
yeah well I mean their own I talk about
their communication with the trees yeah
and I mean that I know that was just
fascinating and and again until because
of that because of the Xena site you
know they no contact was to be allowed
with another species yeah which is what
you know set them back so far because
when they tried to plant
Lenalee bone Pippo and let me thought
they had just tortured him to death
because they had the initiation yeah and
so when they finally you know when ender
came in there and actually just broke
the wall to communication and said you
know that because you could tell it was
a religious ceremony what we are doing
or some kind of a ritualistic ceremony
so I you know that you know I but they
had their own thing I mean but when they
needed something they just tapped and
some to a tree until it completely
turned into what they wanted to do near
up talk about me library you know that
there is here's the me laugh a but it it
was just you know I thought so they have
that and now the high for the hive Queen
and the buggers prop I think had that
you know Falana kind of thing but I
don't think there was any real changing
there's there's points from the work
where I don't know if it's ender or one
of the other people says that the hive
Queen thinks religion is the religion
stuff is all nonsense doesn't understand
what what the piggies are interested in
it for or the humans are interested in
it for yeah but I mean that that the
thing about the Falana connection is
also relevant there we have religion in
part and we all we have religion in part
because we also have communication so
there's something that's not yet figured
out not yet seen you know when we talk
about people having faith it's not
really faith if you actually know what's
what's going on you don't need faith
and so the hive Queen everything is
totally instantaneous she ends when all
of her what workers or workers yeah all
should and all the other hive queens now
in each of the other hive Queens now so
they don't think a little need they
don't need religion to make sense of the
universe they have something different
well the sense they medium you know I
think they have the information that
they're yeah there's useful for them so
that was there was another really
interesting theme the way that that card
used ansible
and sort of developed it out so at first
it's it's it's just like well there's a
communication device right and it allows
jane to grow into something that is
spread out in her consciousness through
all this and so we have communication at
a distance but then it starts to get
trickier in the third book because
there's explanations of what's really
going on there in terms of subatomic
particles and their connection to each
other and this theorization about could
it you know be souls or things like that
and here card is actually i think
drawing on the thought of an 18th
century philosopher Gottfried Wilhelm
Leibniz who wrote a book he wrote
several books the one that this would be
connected to would be either his
discourse on metaphysics or his
popularization and they called the Monod
ology and the idea was that whole
universe and all of our consciousnesses
are all these little monads that are
like it's tinier than anything right
think of them as not even like atoms and
we would be like entire what he called
intellikeys of monads and i mean there's
a lot more to the theory than that but
the basic notion is that there's like
for each of us there would be a
top-level monad that all these other
ones are
- and that's the way that he's
portraying things in terms of this
falada clink with how it ties in with a
person's will and how people get
connected with each other in
relationships there's this big
discussion about that about halfway
through the third book and I think that
he is actually without naming him
drawing on likenesses theory to do so
because it sounds pretty similar to
goods you know and what it then allows
is action at a distance communication
you know talking and talking in not just
mystical but more scientific terms about
how us being is a conversation with each
other connects us with each other all
the time we're going to see a similar
concept when we get to xenogenesis oh
yeah you're right you're right Octavia
Butler yeah has a similar concept in the
xenogenesis service yeah
after what she calls the things those
connections yeah there's a word for it
right now yeah but it's you know
so what Kurt is doing is he's he's
really playing around some high-level
metaphysics but I found interesting was
when earth spread out after the form of
war yeah and fell the other planets how
how nationalistic it was how Native it
yeah it's like everything having a
Chinese to be over here and you have to
be Normandy be over here and you have to
be Indian to be over here and you have
to be it was very nativist it was very
we don't want other people yeah well we
want our own people anyone they were
talking about the migration trying to
figure out who when I would ship it was
like they were very the people who lead
in the groups were very we only want
this kind of person even though the
world said you have to have a mix there
has to be a percentage of diversity yes
and you know what else was strange about
that tier or so a lot of the leaders are
people who went through the
and so they were thrown in with people
from all different nationalities had to
get along with them they're not up when
I have to work together to do the Lord
yeah and I have a friend who's half
Tanzanian half Norwegian and his parents
met at school so where would he go
yeah which ship does he get oh yeah but
for simply things like that are
happening in the underverse - it's not
good that's getting together other
people will be mixed so yeah well and
even though the authorities tried to
stop that from happening by making sure
there were people from other ethnicities
backgrounds on each ship there was still
a majority they really have an
interesting story - like what's
Chinatown on truant I'm like yeah so I
think once they actually are on the
planets though there's a lot less
migration then you then we have a here
on earth right because if we want to if
we want to migrate like let's say we all
decide we get a wild hair or like that's
it we're all going to China
screw the US you know and we're all
gonna stay together as Americans right
so we I don't we picked that a city
right we're all going to go to Shanghai
you know they'll be like you know
millions of us and we have like you know
America we have cities cities in the
south and in Central America
so the point is it's super easy to do
because we just get on a plane right but
if you have to travel for you know
generations yeah essentially why is that
as long while you're in the thing right
it takes it doesn't take that a couple
of weeks and it's like what yeah yeah 20
years so so if it's that sort of
investment you're probably not gonna
emigrate unless you really really have
to like the reason why I loose itami I
becomes a colony is because the other
resilient world there's too many people
on it so but they go off as their own
Brazilians and you know Brazilian yeah
peace and Catholic yeah this for me I
mean it was that and I didn't really
know side was
now the formic Wars is understand it is
no such a grunt it's not what it's
called there in earth unaware and earth
a fire earth awakens' that's where they
start calling in the form of war yeah oh
it wasn't in the just the book and
risking no he's living though he's
living the form of course okay those are
the four nerd wars all right well I
didn't um it shows up in shadow of the
hegemon well didn't read any there only
read and those schemes speaker for the
dead and chilly another mind so anyway
and so I'm just very limited in how much
that so as much as I get done okay cuz I
was just wondering how because I didn't
remember that when they were splitting
this all off and everything up suddenly
just showed up on these places yeah I
didn't know they got there so yeah it's
a useful science fiction device to have
all these ships that can go wherever you
want
well in until another mind by the time
you know Jane really gets the stone
would be people without even the
starship she can just start you know
like starching you dude you really lucky
lies engine is like a transporter yeah I
think the migration happens the Xenocide
which migration the first migration off
of Earth that's the only book I didn't I
couldn't find it so I didn't read it the
first way right well no that'd be an
understatement they start there they
start again the vendor's game yeah they
start the individual there's more of it
then during Xenocide yeah cuz right
after Enders game of speaker for the
dead and then then they're already
sitting on that's all rotating John yeah
so then that that's why I didn't know
what happened
so the Cena said must have gone back
time okay yeah and and I mean he's he's
sort of flushing out more and more of
the universe as the books go on he's
smart - he doesn't through characters
discussing doesn't say you know by the
way you know five hundred years ago this
is what happened you think like that he
always does it through conversations at
the camp another thing I thought was
interesting and Ender's Game
but you know if it everything with these
kids maybe they like this demosthenes
just so I can speak tonight demosthenes
and luck yeah you know why cuz I'm on
like five pills and nothing's working
here I'm not continuous I just have this
horrible wasn't it going on and so I'm
taking all of this crap to get rid of
this stuff in its traffic it's making me
nuts anyway with those two where do they
like eight nine and they're writing this
these you know that's brilliant
oh my god and then you know what is it
and then you know they end up
formulating everything else going on at
the time you know all the conversations
and everything all the political
everything is going on around these
little kids I just think it's just
amazing yeah you know the notion that
you could sort of break in to form
policy by presenting arguments you know
that's part of my like yeah that's part
of our sort of mythos right the
Federalist Papers and and then works
sometimes but not most of the time and
it seems to be really really hard to
break in so these kids are you know
extraordinarily gifted and using the
internet or whatever
well I'm Valentine did a lot of that too
much she read the articles under a false
name yeah well I guess she was
demosthenes yes I bet they take these
two philosophers of the John Locke I
mean the other Peter cuz he was sort of
an odd duck
that's understanding it cruel creepy but
then here not up to be a little bit well
with the squirrels I mean that was just
plain creepy and you know he turns about
a genius in his own way yes and then but
then he turns back you know which is
I've known some kids like that and they
they didn't turn out to be geniuses they
just turned out to be pretty pretty
strange and twisted you know some kids
were doing he'd be like wow you know and
we and we didn't really have the
vocabulary to to identify it as like
there's probably a mental illness there
we just we used words like creepy and
you know that kids really weird the
x-men brothers gonna kill me tomorrow I
mean you know that's kind of yeah like
my door because I'm afraid of this kid
and yeah so yeah but I just thought that
was really interesting that those the
abilities of these I don't they're just
kind of genetically bred that way
because they were looking for some super
genius to help them much above the worse
there was some suggestion that there was
some breeding programs going on don't
try to create ender okay those there
there was a suggestion in Ender's Game
yeah that there had been some matching
programs and his parents have been
matched yeah because this kind of
brilliance just as noticing they're all
waiting programs going on to try to find
the kids the right guy and being a third
- he was a third a special privilege
because his brother and sister almost
were they are yeah I suppose if you're a
novelist it probably pays to make your
your characters super smart and great
reflexes because then you can get them
out of whatever situation you need to
sort of build them up you know I know
they made a movie out of Enders game
because I remember seeing any Jerusalem
charities just a mall of all of those
antics in the battle rooms I said oh
yeah I remember that seeing that there's
a mile ago they did that within the last
five years I think yeah that was you
know thinking so I read Ender's Game
around Christmastime and then I read the
more recently and I remember trying to
sort of like visualize some of the
things that card said we're going out of
the battle room and I can't have a tough
time with it sometimes
did you guys were able to visualize like
what I was because I saw that movie oh
that's why I was thinking I saw I know
what they're talking about because I saw
him but this legs doing this and yeah
and then the freezing and that's what
really and the well not so much of
positioning that I had to figure out but
that's just some logic you know where
you have to position up and down and
right in that kind of thing but that
when when some of those things like
hating me behind
yeah I agree and I said oh I know I saw
this so I have visual II seen it which
helped okay you know with that because
otherwise they would have been up and it
was a little prolonged like Jesus we
have to detail it's interesting to the
so all that training although all that
you know shooting each other and stuff
like that it's not really preparing them
as such for what they're ultimately
doing which is directing ships this is
strategy but well here right and it's
building up that sort of like
flexibility of thinking and coordinating
larger sets of units but they're not
really using their bodies anymore once
they're there coordinating the ships
well I mean even even when Enders in the
shower and that Spanish guy came
remember his name was gonna come after
me he knew the only weapon he had was a
bar of soap
I mean oh that is really using anything
that's there as a strategy yeah you know
I mean he's soaking up some he got so
stupid I think I couldn't even show that
they could do it yeah in a second he
could think of that now who would do
that normally yeah that takes some
really know who made a career really
Hahn of like turning every single
possible thing into a weapon in kung-fu
movies oh I can check any gym can start
him he started some crazy things like
cooking kungfu you know
we're like that's the Bruce Lee was his
predecessor well Bruce did Bruce Lee
didn't like he didn't like he was really
great but I don't think he like turned
everything everything like you know if
Jackie Chan would take that that job
yeah where he'd like first throw the
water in somebody's face and then stick
the couple for his head that that
resourcefulness you know but he was
doing a kind of a gag I think what well
I think the the exercises in the room
where they were exercising wasn't so
much about their flexibility yeah as
strategy with bodies moving around ships
yeah because a body could be a ship
moving behind a planet what would the
freezing what would be equivalent to the
physic being on the ships
I think that was just you know that the
freezing was in your shot so now you
can't move that if you if you mess up
your target yeah okay
if you mess up the ship becomes a target
or though whatever it is you're trying
it becomes a target okay
becomes vulnerable yeah makes sense so
it was more training their minds to make
decisions based on positioning and
movement within within with in zero
gravity yeah yeah well like it was just
it was just how it was survival I mean
this is what ender was he knew everyone
is out to get him
yeah and his survival instincts were so
ridiculously strong that he would just
come up with things instantaneously but
when you grow up with his brother yeah
he's gonna tell you he developed that
instinct yeah early on well the other
kids were beating a lot too but even
though he I mean I killed two people
didn't even realize he killed all right
I mean the guy in the shower because he
knew he was coming to kill him and
that's why he did this woman and the kid
and and that other kid in the beginning
because he had been picking on him yeah
and he didn't even have realized that
what he was doing at the time was was
deadly yeah he talks about that in the
third book later on when
there's something like there somebody's
trying to it is being kind of kind of
not tough you know he brings up that you
know once you've actually killed
somebody you start to think a lot more
about these these things and take it
more seriously what is make of graph as
we were sort of finishing up well that's
that's what I was thinking about how it
was like this conscious going on you
know he was doing making all the moral
decisions yeah that weren't really very
moral and then whoever he was talking to
was more the conscience of it and saying
well you really but yes this has to be
done because you said you have to save
the bill yeah and I think on some level
graft really really did you know like
ender I mean if you believe look in I
think but yeah by the end it's clearly
well and um but you know he had to
destroy him as a child to do whatever he
did to I mean I've got a five year old
we've got a five year old with a
grandchild and I could never see him do
what you want to enjoy it's doing it
like years old if you knew that in order
to save the rest of the world and you
couldn't substitute yourself in your
your grand child's place would you be
able to would you be able to conceive of
doing the sort of stuff that grafted to
ender remember it's a whole world yeah
no I I know well it'd have to not be
your own grand job that's that's
something's true as I said yeah take
some kid off the street and you know the
whole world is at stake
behold you the race is that stake you
know well that's why they were doing
that little justification piece before
each chapter you know talking it over
yeah I'm saying you know this is wrong
but we're gonna do it anyway
what's its pop quota oh good of the many
outweigh so that's that's the
utilitarian yeah logic there yeah yeah
yeah you can't really get it through all
tourism very often that somebody would
be willing to do it I don't think anyone
well you know there probably would be
candidates and that would probably
disqualify them
from being good candidates because they
wanted to do right because why would
somebody want to subject themselves to
that sort of training no you know there
is also the soldier in der kills by
having him fly into the hive if I recall
correctly it started like sending
someone into a death trap and they don't
know that there are real soldiers
obeying their every word but there was a
real person there who was trained to
just agree with whatever they said yes
it was there's some level of conscious
selves well the pilot fellowships were
trained to whatever they were told to do
look at you
they're taking I mean all those pilots
are essentially on a suicide mission
because that happens against them we're
so bad well our own military trains
people that way they're trained to take
the orders not to second-guess it not to
think about it not to think about I'm
gonna get killed if I do this well here
that is simply taking orders for the
training who would willingly subject
themselves to that kind of tearing down
training well I think a lot of the
people who would do that would be bad
they would they would have motives for
doing it look I like to kill people so
this is great for me well you don't want
them in there you know but that's who we
get sometimes in any law enforcement we
get people like that yeah that's true
the savior complex who just want to go
in there just for the sake don't you
have people you yeah I don't know well
and so that the interesting thing with
that would be how how long does that
continue on right some people some
people do have that Savior complex like
when I was working in the prison we
would see this sort of thing people be
like oh I'm gonna volunteer in the
prison because these poor guys and I
mean the prisoners would see that and
they're like we're gonna turn this
person eat see that feeling if you came
in with a savior complex and saying you
know I know what I got to do this to
save the world I think they would be
bound by some ethical some morality I
think they would be yeah well when
cocaine shop hopefully they know I mean
that they would not be able to follow
through with what they
to do because in the end they would
somehow not be able to do what you
destroy the whole yes I'm not sure I
mean I think that's going strapped it's
like one thing more interesting as if he
had grandkids on earth mmm then this
Ward was viscerally like he's attached
to Endor emotionally but he also have
attachments on earth yeah like would I
trade in a kid I loved for the rest of
the world that's only an abstract ideal
for me I don't know you know so he kept
getting getting weightier and weightier
in weightier so I think cuz they by the
end they said he was really getting to
the point of good Hurley fitnah chair so
I think he at the stress and whatever he
was doing
um I pick up all these little yeah just
just just the stress of having to do all
this you know I think yeah just you know
I he probably was just you know making
his health and everything else you know
I think in terms of got you completing
the task when you're talking about I
think it depends on how you see the
other side if you see them as jour yeah
no problem just kill you know if you see
them as brad.leah well yeah or II
noticed that's a whole nother story do
you go through with this even if you're
gonna protect their universe you know
yeah yeah here I've kept the universe
it's what that foreignness it's how how
separate you see them from yourself
yeah well it's cozy because it is the
other and you know the other yeah yeah
you know it's interesting so Janos means
for right but among the Greeks had also
meant guest and you'd have these things
essentially guest friendships that would
come up through families like Odysseus
right in the Odyssey you see Telemachus
goes to Pylos and goes to Sparta and he
gets received and there is like talk
about you know giving him this gift and
all that it was like a traditional thing
you know aristotle actually points out
that this is not really necessarily
about a faction it's just kind of
business transactions okay but they are
there are certain like rules to have
here the guest comes in
can wash their feet give them something
to eat
you know so you get it give them a nice
wine serving bowls something to take
home and then they're supposed to bring
something themselves there is this whole
other thing you know killing your guests
well that's about as low as you can get
you know in for the Greeks that are
killing your parents you know yeah so
it's kind of interesting the different
senses of saying they're not just Greeks
all through that Middle Eastern that's
true yeah eastern Mediterranean area
it's the same kind of guest friendship
yes it's an upper class thing it's not
not everybody because who can afford to
do it not everybody can
[Music]